How do you build a better world? There are
so many well-known, urgent places you might
start: malaria, carbon emissions, tax evasion,
the drug trade, soil erosion, water pollution…
Donald Winnicott deserves his place in history
because of the dramatic simplicity of his
approach. He proposed that the happiness of
the human race depended ultimately not so
much on external political issues, but on
the way parents bring up their children.
Born in 1896, Winnicott was Britain’s first
medically-trained child psychoanalyst.
Although he had no children of his own, he
played a crucial and devoted role in public
education around child-rearing, delivering
some 600 talks on the BBC, tirelessly lecturing
around the country and authoring 15 books,
among which the bestselling collection of
essays, Home is Where We Start From.
It was rather strange that Winnicott should even have been English given that his country
was notorious, then as now, for its lack of
tenderness and its resistance to introspection.
And yet Winnicott’s brand of psychoanalysis
was, on closer inspection, peculiarly English.
There was a characteristic English modesty
about what he saw as the point of child psychoanalysis.
His famous radio series was simply titled
The Ordinary Devoted Mother and Her Baby.
He wanted to help people to be, in his famous
formulation,
good enough
parents; not brilliant or perfect ones (as
other nations might have wished), but just
OK.
So what would it take, in his eyes, to encourage
the ‘good enough’ parent? Winnicott put
forward a number of suggestions:
Winnicott begins by impressing on his audience
how psychologically fragile an infant is.
It doesn’t understand itself, it doesn’t
know where it is, it is struggling to stay
alive, it has no way of grasping when the
next feed will come, it can’t communicate
with itself or others.
Winnicott’s work never loses sight of this,
and he therefore repeatedly insists that it
is those around the infant who have to adapt
so as to do everything to interpret the child’s
needs and not impose demands for which the
child is not ready.
For example, Winnicott knew what violence,
what hate there could be in a healthy infant.
Referring to what happens if a parent forgets
a feed, he cautioned: ‘If you fail him,
it must feel to him as if the wild beasts
would gobble him up.’
But though the infant might sometimes want
to kill and destroy, it is vital for the parents
to allow rage to expend itself, and for them
not in any way to be threatened or moralistic
about ‘bad’ behaviour: ‘If a baby cries
in a state of rage … and yet the people
round him remain calm and unhurt, this experience
greatly strengthens his ability to see that
what he feels to be true is not necessarily
real.’
Parents are delighted when infants and children
follow their rules. Such children are called
good. Winnicott was very scared of ‘good’
children.
He believed that they were the children of
parents who could not tolerate too much bad
behaviour and demanded compliance too early
and too strictly. This would lead, in Winnicott’s
formulation, to the emergence of a
False Self
– a persona that would be outwardly compliant,
outwardly good, but was suppressing its vital instincts.
In Winnicott’s scheme, adults who can’t
be creative, who are somehow a little dead
inside, are almost always the children of
parents who have not been able to tolerate
defiance, parents who have made their offspring
‘good’ way before their time, thereby
killing their capacity to be properly good,
properly generous and kind.
Every failure of the environment forces a
child to adapt prematurely. For example, if
the parents are too chaotic, the child quickly
tries to over-think the situation. Its rational
faculties are over-stimulated (it may, in
later life, try to be an intellectual).
A parent who is depressed might unwittingly
force the child to be too cheerful – giving
it no time to process its own melancholy feelings.
Winnicott saw the dangers in a child who,
in his words, has to ‘look after mother’s
mood’.
Winnicott had a special hatred for ‘people
who are always jogging babies up and down
on their knees trying to produce a giggle.’
This was merely their way of warding off their
own sadness, by demanding laughter from a
baby who might have very different things
on its mind.
The primordial act of parental health for
Winnicott is simply to be able to tune out
of oneself for a time in the name of empathising
with the ways and needs of a small, mysterious,
beautiful fragile person whose unique otherness
must be acknowledged and
respected in full measure.
Many of the parents Winnicott saw were worn
down by their labours. Winnicott tried to
bolster them by reminding them of the utmost
importance of what they were doing. They were,
in their own way, as significant to the nation
as the Prime Minister and the Cabinet.
Winnicott called parenting: ‘the only real
basis for a healthy society, and the only
factory for the democratic tendency in a country’s
social system.’
In his descriptions of what parents should
do for their children, Winnicott was in effect
referring to a term which he rarely mentioned
directly: love. We often imagine love to be
about a magical intuitive ‘connection’
with someone. But, in Winnicott’s writings,
we get a different picture. It’s about a
surrender of the ego, a putting aside of one’s
own needs and assumptions, for the sake of
close, attentive listening to another, whose
mystery one respects, along with a commitment
not to get offended, not to retaliate, when
something ‘bad’ emerges, as it often does
when one is close to someone, child or adult.
Since Winnicott’s death, we’ve collectively
grown a little better at parenting.
But only a little. We may spend more time
with our children, we know in theory that
they matter a lot, but we’re arguably still
failing at the part Winnicott focused on:
ADAPTATION
We still routinely fail to suppress our own
needs or stifle our own demands when we’re
with a child.
We’re still learning how to love our children
– and that, Winnicott would argue, is why
the world is still full of the walking-wounded,
people of outward ‘success’ and respectability
who are nevertheless not quite ‘real’
inside and inflict their wounds on others.
We’ve a way to go until we are fully ‘good
enough.’ It’s a task – Winnicott would
have insisted – that’s in its own way
as important as any other.